get ready to Shake Rattle and rock this
weekend it's the Viva Las Vegas
rockabilly Music Festival back in the
valley once again Candace Charles has
already got the party going she's at the
Orleans this morning to profile our
longest running festival Candace good
morning to you how's the sock hop
the cats from all over the world have
come here for the 26th Viva Las Vegas
Rockabilly Weekend Hollow Fest has
sustained we'll take a look the music
baby
thank you
[Music]
first that's the number one reason for
Viva Las Vegas music fashion and hot rod
it was Viva Las Vegas rockabilly Music
Festival is all about and Tom Ingram
it's a great line behind it all and when
I first said I wanted to do Weekender in
Vegas and my friends are
no you won't get a place in Vegas that
was 26 years ago this weekend Festival
goers can experience four days of
non-stop 50s music from bands from all
over the world but that's not all the
car show where all the cars have to be
built before 1964. we've got burlesque
shows we have different sorts of meetups
it is now the longest running music fest
in Vegas we do it by sticking to what we
first set out to do bringing rockabilly
music back to the masses with some of
the Legends like Chuck Berry and Jerry
Lee Lewis now gone vlv recreates some of
those iconic performances and brings on
new Talent like these guys
the centuries this is definitely the
most important one I'd say in terms of
like getting out there and getting
people who really care about the music
that you're playing you know to hear you
look forward to it all year we hope they
walk away thinking wow that was awesome
[Music]
yeah and there are still tickets
available for the four day Fest tickets
start at 40 bucks for the car show and
you'll get the headlines at the car show
it's 250 for the four day tickets we got
to cover more details on the website.com
but now live from The Orleans Happyville
Las Vegas now
[Music]
[Applause]